petit rappel du concept des gens qui ne
se connaissent pas sont jugés
compatibles par des spécialistes et se
rencontrent pour la première fois la
cérémonie de mariage hier il ya eu
énormément de rebondissements vous avez
un petit récap et dans un instant vous
allez voir le petit drame qui a eu lieu
hier soir j'en ai versé ma petite larme
oui il n'y avait qu'une seule larme dans
mes yeux
aucune alarme
[Rires]
hier soir dans bye au premier regard
florent manaudou et ses potes nageurs
ont offert des cadeaux bien pourri à
geoffrey comme des cartes à jouer une
photo une raquette de ping pong un jeton
ou un briquet kamoulox pour son voyage
de noces ce geoffrey avait envie de
faire beaucoup trop de choses avec sa
nouvelle femme pourra courir la sûreté
dans le sable face venir tellement de
choses qu'il en a même oublié de faire
une autre activité seul cheveu d'écouté
que ce soit l'inter hier soir et on n'a
pas fait un amour et le pauvre a
visiblement passé toute la nuit sur la
béquille
et sinon pauline a découvert la porte de
damien son nouveau mari qui a comme par
hasard les mêmes que sa dulcinée chez
lui au point que c'en est presque
flippant eux comme chez toi le tabouret
la même couleur la piste je crois que
c'est le même que chez moi la table ça
va motiver aussi ressembler
je savais que j'allais aussi
beaucoup de gens qui réagissent sur ma
photo encore dans le temps
il ya une amie qui va sauter exactement
la même veine que kelly voilà donc bravo
les grands esprits se rencontrent hier
franck à pied tout
arrêté
sera demain un grand capitou également
président de jeunes à bien le chari
énormément
continuer un bien entendu mais les
romantiques c'est joli ça vieillit on
donnerait pas qu'ils avaient des baobabs
en ile de france
et de la fin de film ça fait parler aux
arbres cyril oui bien sûr je parle aux
arbres et les arbres on me parlait
toujours en costume et moi non pas mal
de choses sur vous
mondy de trois personnes qu'il fallait
virer les armes
vous avez donc mariés au premier regard
quelques quelqu'un voulait réagir oui
tout de suite là dessus parce que je
vous montrais le drame qui savoie la wii
avec moi c'est le drame qui m'a la
justice vous en parlerez condamne sera
sur le g g hier soir
c'est la tournure qu'a pris la relation
entre est midi et frédéric pourtant
compatible à 84% selon les experts ah
oui les experts manhattan mais j'espère
me m on avait dit qu'il serait
compatible à 84%
si tout se passait bien jusqu'ici leur
voyage de noces à prague a tourné au
cauchemar
la tourner au vinaigre
la moutarde lui monter au nez
l'expression et ils ont pris une
décision que benjamin castaldi connais
par coeur leur divorce
regardez
pour moi
c'est le manque de respect quand tu
quittes a appelé le soir où tu veux te
poser c'est parti dans tous les sens
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
on est des sanguins qui sont bien oui
mais je vais pas te mentir je tâte
inventé qu'est ce que je sais mais je
suis pas sanguine h 24 je suis passé en
ligne sans raison je n'en pouvais tout
simplement plus et c'était tout
simplement il faut que vous apprenez à
dédramatiser
ça va mieux
[Musique]
moi je préfère arrêter la divorcée tout
comme toi j'ai été déçu tout comme toi
j'ai vraiment aussi avec sortir de la
relation et je veux qu'on dit mars
voilà il ya un drame incroyable sachez
que ils sont très mauvais termes
aujourd'hui emilie a tenté de revenir
après l'émission et ça s'était mal passé
apparemment aujourd'hui ils vivent
reclus chacun de leur côté voilà face à
leur destin face à leur vie gilles je
crois vous avez des enfants non j'ai été
très déçu parce qu'un couple n'est fait
que de disputent d'engueulades hélas
hélas ils ont et je trouve qu'ils ont
abandonné tout de suite c'est à dire que
là il ya là la scène évidemment on
enlève les alliances symbolique on les
met sur la table mais pour moi parce que
ils sont chacun en plus par an donc moi
je pensais qu'ils avaient une
implication totale et j'ai tout de même
l'impression cyril à la fin de cette
séquence qu'ils ne croyaient pas en leur
mariage est l'explication suivante c'est
que je vais vous le dire je pense que ce
mariage était fake voilà je ré ans qui
n'avait pas vraiment envie de se marier
que c'était faux que ce n'était pas un
vrai mariage est qu'à la première
occasion ils ont renoncé j'ai été déçu
parce que on n'abandonne pas si vite oui
qui dit moi je suis pas d'accord avec
toi parce que c'est là où on se rend
compte qu'il a peut-être pas de science
exacte et qui a pas de pourcentage en
amour et qu'au final se sont rendu
compte que même s'ils avaient des points
communs bac niveau caractère ça passait
pas du tout lui il est très dur dans la
vie il laisse rien passer et elle elle
est très excessive ils sont rendu compte
que ça marchait pas et s'ils se séparent
voilà la ré so connaissance à benjamin
très bien mais je sais ça moments
difficiles donc il
faut c'est vrai que c'est beau mais sans
déconner quand tu dois décidé de
divorcer c'est pas facile je vous dis
franchement c'est pas facile mais ça
c'est pas pareil quand même
elle y en a toujours un qui est plus
meurt le kloet ccsa problème et c'est
souvent vous c'était souvent moi pas
n'ont pas n'ont pas tout le temps
franchement pas tout le temps une fois
sur deux le plus je peux ce parti que
leurs avants kelly a les chiffres
je suis plus partie que qu'on m'a
quittée en fait voilà mais c'est très
mal et vous servez
frais la photo à côté de l'arbre pour
l'illustration oui j'ai tu veux dire
quelque chose non après c'est moi cette
émission évidemment il ya des couples
qui se sont rencontrés grâce à cette
émission qui ont fondé des familles qui
ont eu des bébés le couple de l'année
dernière par exemple été absolument
magnifique mais après c'est vrai qu'il
ya un truc un peu fait parce que moi je
crois pas au pourcentage aux critères
des algues et tout ça j'y crois pas et à
partir du moment où effectivement on se
marie en deux minutes on passe à un
voyage de noces comme ça et puis après
on divorce en deux secondes ouais
forcément tous les trucs était un petit
peu artificielle quoi donc moi je n'y
crois pas c'est un an après le jeu en
vaut peut être la chandelle pour ceux
pour qui ça marche pourquoi pas et si ça
marche on a aidé les parents mon rythme
non mais je suis d'accord mais je pense
que les caméras malgré tout elle
manipule un peu les réactions des gens
c'est à dire que est-ce qu'on peut tout
de suite au vu de ce que ça engagé comme
programmé tout ça est ce que décidément
ce soir j'ai la côte quand je parle
est ce que vraiment on va tout de suite
foire et le programme est ce que tout de
suite on va dire qu'on n'est pas faits
l'un pour l'autre j'ai un fond qui
partent en voyage de noces et isoler
prague pourquoi pas et puis finalement
après il envoie tout valser aller
la production de l'émission bape savais
que j'étais proche d une chaîne que
j'aime énormément ils pensent à une
déclinaison de l'émission avec une star
on a les premières images du pilote
regarde des hommes célibataires venus de
toute la france vont tout faire pour
essayer de séduire une femme
tu es magnifique
malheureusement pour eux l'élue de leur
coeur n'a pas prévu de leur faciliter la
tâche
c'est là qu'ils sont le goal est celle
qu'on trouve plus joli et bien de gagner
c'est comme ça intimidation g pardon
mais tu es moisi de l'intérieur comme du
roquefort menace
c'est pas madame coup de pression que
c'est indigne et c'est dégueulasse et
qu'elle est du côté des collabos cette
femme maîtrise toutes les techniques de
dissuasion les plus agressifs plus tôt
si à ce moment là alors si vous
souhaitez en prendre plein la gueule
pour votre première venue en plateau
j'ai dit ce que je pense inscrivez-vous
tout de suite à maillet au premier
regard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aux équipes
sachez que je ne veux pas m'inscrire
pour y être surpris ouais mais calme-toi
copains